last year I got a chance to watch the
new Star Wars movie which was fantastic
but one thing kept bugging me I don't
know if you guys noticed this or not in
this entire technically advanced world I
did not see a single ad anywhere which
was totally shocking almost as shocking
is not knowing when Navy is which you
guys do know but for those at home an
AED is an automated external different
later it's the device used when your
heart goes into cardiac arrest to shock
it back into a normal rhythm or as one
of the guys I was teaching a class to
referred to it as the shocking hardy box
thing so but I really can't blame the
Empire since you know health and safety
regulations aren't really their first
order of business though even if we I
think worse than not having an AED would
be if there was one there but just no
one knew where to find it
these devices can drastically increase
your chance of survival almost like a
con con on Hoth but I am pretty sure
that that stormtrooper is going to be
toast regardless if we have an AED or
not since what happens is that chest
plate is going to be quite hard to get
off and like that Taunton the AED has a
very short window of time in which is
highly effective in this case around
basically abouts we've got to use it
within the first 10 minutes the Jedi on
the other hand have no problems with
their outfits those robes open straight
up you can place the pads right onto the
chest so upper right hand side of the
chest lower left wait for the unit to
sort of determine if it's a shockable
rhythm and get ready to shock but the
Jedi do have a problem they have a head
appendage issue and so I can be totally
clear thinking I'm ready to go but I'm
accidentally touching a tentacle and
inadvertently shocking myself so before
you hit that button make sure you are
clear and everyone else is clear
going back to that to that stormtrooper
if I did get that chest light off in
time what would you do if you suddenly
found there was a wookie under there or
possibly an Ewok too
well lucky for us in the kit there's
actually a razor and we can use that to
shave the chest on the upper right hand
side and the lower left will keys also
have another problem they have an
accessory issue so what we want to do is
that we want to remove these anything
between the two pads we want to remove
since it can cause something called
arcing for those whose own arcing is
remember the emperor when he shoots
electricity at the end of his fingers
that would be kind of like arcing
another thing that oh by the way he
creates that by wearing wool socks under
his robes we can also get arcing if we
have an extremely wet chest the
electricity travels across the surface
instead of through the heart we can
correct this with the immortal words of
Douglas Adams don't panic
which most of us have done today and
also always having a towel so good words
to go by the metal bikini unfortunately
this is where panic sets in like the
modern brought we have to make sure we
remove because this can cause severe
because severe arcing along with burns
but unfortunately this opens up an issue
that's almost as controversial talking
about the prequels the mere mention of
the word nipples and people get a little
bit of tizzy
by the way that is not a nipple that's a
cupcake so chances are if you do have to
use this this is going to be on someone
you know and remember everyone has
nipples except for Java but he does love
cupcakes
speaking about Java if we do have to use
an AED on him remember pads placements
the same even though he doesn't have
nipples so it's going to be upper right
hand side lower left the preferred
method if we were going to here we're
shocking getting ready to go after we've
done the shock one of the things we need
to do is remember is to do compression
the preferred method of compression is
30 compressions and two breaths in the
center of the chest between the nipples
pressing down at least two inches no
more than two and a half at four at a
rate of at least 100 beats a minute no
more than 120 unfortunately due to the
size of Jabba's mouth and also when he
puts in said mouth we may not want to
actually sort of
due to mouth-to-mouth parts so instead
we can do compression only CPR the way
of remembering the compression only part
is we can actually use the Imperial
March I would sing it for you
unfortunately that would be more
something than interrogation droid would
do ah
Yoda so little guy like a baby what we
do is we basically treat him like a baby
in the sense that we're going to place
one pad in the center of the chest and
one of the back if we place them both in
the front they can either be too close
and caused severe arcing so we want to
avoid that hopefully this helped to
clarify and put some some light on some
of the darker issues of using an AED in
the Star Wars universe or any University
total I'll leave you with one point
remember if you do find yourself dealing
with a Wookiee do not shave the entire
wookie this takes way too much time and
it only pisses them off thank you very
much
[Applause]